le président de l'assemblée de
martinique est avec nous ce matin dans
son caddie bonjour claude lise un bon
jour qu'en dise il ya tout juste une
semaine le président de la république
emmanuel macron disait plus de
décentralisation plus de responsabilités
plus de compétences mais aussi de
responsabilité sous-entendu en local
qu'en pensez-vous une semaine après eh
bien écoutez si on me dit plus de
responsabilités plus de responsabilités
plus de décentralisation
moi je ne peux être que d'accord mais je
dis mais pour tous est un animal blessé
père disparaît donc il y ait derrière
souvent plaint du fait que l'état et
transférer des compétences sans les
moyens des fissures bien sûr c'est pour
ça que je m'empresse de dire il s'agit
de savoir ce qu'il ya derrière il ya un
beau concept qui est mis en avant celui
de différenciation mais ce n'est pas
nouveau un le mot et le concept sont
utilisés depuis belle lurette
en tout cas depuis depuis les années 80
de la depuis la décentralisation de
françois mitterrand mais nous sommes
dans une france très jacobine et et le
vieux jacobinisme est encore prégnant à
droite comme à gauche d'ailleurs ce qui
fait que lorsque l'on me parle de tenir
compte des réalités locales des
singularités locales ne pas dire des
spécificités bon jeu j'écoute je suis
preneur
je veux voir ce qu'il ya derrière parce
que on sent que c'est une
cette prise de conscience de fait
évident ce à dire que chaque pays
d'outre-mer à une singularité à cause de
son histoire sa géographie culture sa
série noire d'outre-mer à ce jour
effectuée avec le préfet deux petites
choses avant nous mais il s'agit pas de
petites choses il faut adapter à chaque
réalité les législations les règlements
les normes d'une manière générale bon
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça faut savoir
comment on fait moi ma crainte c'est que
l'on décide ces choses-là d'en haut
en peu de temps j'ai entendu dire que le
président va présenter des propositions
concernant la réforme constitutionnelle
c'est l'instrument majeur de nos
réformes pour la décentralisation la
réforme constitutionnelle
il paraît qu'il va donner des précisions
en juillet là écoutez nous sommes heures
mais oui alors oui mais mes icônes il va
consulter qui outre mer sur ces
questions là pour moi de l'elysée sur le
maroc a pour moi il faut une large
consultation des forces vives avant
toutes les formes
concernant nos problèmes institutionnels
donc pour l'instant vous êtes plutôt
méfiante
je suis méfiant et vous avez envie de
lui dire chiche à emmanuel marc ont
attendu mais d'abord il ya une urgence
il sait très bien qu'à une urgence pour
la martinique oui c'est les gens louent
d'édifier l'outil que nous avons la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
vous n'êtes pas satisfaite du tous deux
commencent à vous tous je j'avais prédit
lors des débats les débats au sénat
puisque à l'époque j'étais sénateur en
2011 j'avais prédit que ça n'irait pas
ce soir non c'est pas une usine à gaz
mais c'est un système qui n'est pas
démocratique et quand un système n'est
pas démocratique
il peut pas être performant donc donc je
pense qu'on pourrait faire mieux que ce
qu'on fait on fait des choses mais on
pourrait faire mieux et surtout j'ai la
crainte pour l'avenir que nous restions
prisonnier de ce mode de fonctionnement
parce que ce qu'avaient voulu les élus
au congrès au départ c'était un système
de contrôle de l'exécutif et c'est pour
ça qu'ils avaient voulu d'une séparation
des pouvoirs mais voyez comment on
traduit une demande pas autre chose on à
linverse en un système qui permet ce
avec les deux auditeurs n'existe tout
simplement mais c'est peut-être parce
que l'actuel président de la sommerau
martinique n'est pas suffisamment ferme
vis-à-vis de l'actuel président de nos
agences non non ce n'est pas une
question de personnalité c'est une
question de d'abord de texte après bien
entendu aller les hommes
ils interprètent les textes au quotidien
mais vous avez un texte qui paie en main
des dysfonctionnements graves puisque le
texte permet je n'ai pas dit qu'il
prescrit ça mais il permet alors
l'assemblée soit entièrement dépendante
de l'exécutif
c'est précisément ce que n'avait pas
voulu les lots alors fait pas autant que
peut-on faire
simplement ça je dis que si on veut si
on veut nous donner plus de
responsabilités il faut déjà nous donner
un instrument convenable toujours à
réécrire le fameux secteurs variés ce
sont les élus de la ctc atteint car vous
savez d'un système dans lequel on en est
même si les élus proposent
si le gouvernement n'est pas d'accord ça
passera pas donc des griffons une
concertation d'accord il faut une
ouverture du gouvernement c'est ce que
je lui demande avant de nous parler de
deux délégués de nouvelles compétences
je parle pour la martinique
ailleurs on n'a pas un instrument qui
pose problème
peut-être que les autres sont prêts à
recevoir les compétences manger dit
qu'on a une odeur initiatives d'autres
visites monde ce matin est ce que vous
prendrez l'initiative par exemple
d'aller voir pmn d'aller voir bien sûr
bien sûr d y aller moi je l'aï fait mais
moi je vais redire à ces on nous écoute
et une proposition déjà discuté de ces
questions là un de manière informelle
bien sûr lisez tous les élus actuels
même ce que je ne considérais pas comme
des amis politiques
c'est une affaire qui est trop important
pour l'argentine en tout cas ce que je
pense c'est qu'il ya d'abord cette
urgence c'est ça la première urgence
pour nous en martinique ensuite si on
veut modifier la constitution et moi
j'ai des propositions à faire là dessus
desquels d'autres allons-y
moi je pense qu'il faut réécrire
l'article 73
mais on récupère aussi une partie tu te
dire l'article 73
c'est précisément pour éviter les
problèmes qu'on a connu moi je pense
qu'il faut en finir avec vous voyez ce
système binaire 73 74
il faut que dans la constitution on est
un art peu importe son numéro vous
connais un article qui ouvre le doigt
adaptation en fonction des réalités
puisque le président vous dis je
souhaite que chacun soit considéré dans
sa spécificité dans sa différence
bon il est il épaule la différenciation
mais pour obtenir ça il faut que vous
ayez un article qui permettent de faire
des ce qu'on appelle des statuts à la
carte est entendu qu'il faut maintenir
ce qui est déjà inscrit dans la
constitution
la consultation des populations
concernées des citoyens concernés sur
tout changement c'est ça qui est
important
les gars faut qu'on ait la possibilité
de 2 est ce que l'on veut comme
responsabilité de choisir les domaines
dans lesquels on veut de la
responsabilité
si vous en voulez en matière de logement
ou d'aménagement du territoire ou
d'environnement et cetera eh bien vous
demander au peuple et de rétention alors
écoutez si le président le président
lui-même a reconnu récemment que le
système d'habilitation a dit que ce
système était compliquée long à l'époque
j'avais dit ça c'est cool quand même
c'est en 2003 que ça a été visionnaire
je l'avais dit à l'époque et j'ai
entendu même certains autonomistes de
notamment du ppm qui était heureux
d'avoir ce système là système je disais
à l'époque ça promettait plus que ça ne
permettait aujourd'hui on le constate
alors moi je suis d'accord pour qu'on
n'aille plus loin dans un meilleur
système
concernant tout ce qui nous permet
d'adapter des textes et des règlements
alors le dernier à ce même micro il y
avait quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
la sénatrice catherine conconne qui
disait c'est bien de vouloir proposer
cela c'est bien qui est qui et des
outils mais lien selon elle surtout une
volonté commune à avoir pour ce pays
martic le développement de ce pique
nique d'accord avec bien entendu bien
entendu mais ça c'est une des conditions
l'autre condition étant qu'il ya une
écoute gouvernementale qu'on bat le on
parle de supprimer les n'a d'ailleurs je
pense qu'on ne supprime ou bien comme
disait napoléon iii que ce que l'on en
place donc je ne vois pas ce qu'on va
remplacer ça mais ça va ce qui compte
c'est pas qu'on supprime lina c'est
qu'on supprime une culture ultra
jacobine
par conséquent il faut que l'on cesse de
vouloir faire pour nous surtout des
domaines aussi importants qui
conditionne l'avenir
donc moi je encore une fois je vous dis
qu'il faut une
large concertation alors il faut que
nous nous mettions au moins d'accord sur
quelques principes on peut dire aux
fondamentaux sur quelques grandes
orientations n'est pas forcément
d'accord sur tout évidemment mais de
l'autre côté il faut qu'on veuille bien
discuter avec nous moi ce que je ne veux
pas c'est que dans la précipitation
un peu comme on a fait le texte institue
à la ctm a été rédigé dans la
précipitation débattue dans la
précipitation votée dans la
précipitation
je ne souhaite pas que un texte surtout
s'il est question de réformer la
constitution c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on réforme la prostitution
je ne souhaite pas qu'on modifie une
fois de plus comme on l'a fait en 2003
sans nous consulter suffisamment les
articles qui nous concerne c'est sur ça
que je pense que c'est une affaire trop
sérieuse pour qu'elle soit batlle et
surtout que lise une restait moins d'une
minute
surtout que les élus de martinique
auront en tête leur prochaine réélection
nous car en train d'en payer bien sûr
via ça je veux ajouter notre élément
c'est qu'il faut aussi que toute
nouvelle délégation de compétences
soient accompagnées aussi des moyens
nécessaires
et puis également que le droit à
l'expérimentation qui est très limitée
en lte est à l'heure actuelle
voyez vous ne pouvez pas expérimenté et
sans que ce que vous expérimentez de
positif ne soient susceptibles d'être
généralisé à toute la france
oh il nous faut une possibilité
d'expérimenter pour nous mêmes
il faut un article 62 quatrième alinéa
qui devront être être améliorée si dans
la constitution dont boyer nous avons
des propositions à faire du travail
on met vraiment en 12 secondes pas plus
que 10
emmanuel macron vous convainc
écoutez moi je trouve qu'elle toujours
hiatus trop grand entre les effets
d'annoncé un kill qui l'a qu'il met en
avant et puis les réalités d'où les
déceptions vous voyez chez beaucoup
merci claude lise président de
l'assemblée de martinique merci d'avoir
été avec nous au lendemain de la fête de
des travailleurs et travailleuses merci
bonne journée